this if not an act of war was certainly
a war like it is now clear that mr.
scruple and his daughter were poisoned
with a military-grade nerve agent of a
type developed by Russia the attack was
reckless indiscriminate and
irresponsible
it's inadvertently someone did become
ill and it was established that it was
exposure to the nerve agent the
government would be in a very difficult
position
to look at Salisbury and to live here is
to wonder where this ends and her the
scenes played out in the heart of
Wiltshire resemble a futuristic film set
in which the future isn't bright here
they're not sure when they'll see the
back of all this of chemical protection
suit specially trained military
personnel machines moving vehicles too
dangerous to touch by human hand in a
deserted city centre Salisbury is a
place unknowing and uneasy with exactly
what happened here eight days after
Sergey scruple and his daughter Yulia
were attacked with a nerve agent the UK
government finally put a name to it and
to the likely perpetrator it is now
clear but mr. scrapple and his daughter
were poisoned with a military-grade
nerve agent of a type developed by
Russia this is part of a group of nerve
agents known as Nova chop based on the
positive identification of this chemical
agent by world leading experts at the
defense Science and Technology
Laboratory at Porton down our knowledge
that Russia has previously produced this
agent and would still be capable of
doing so
Russia's record of conducting
state-sponsored assassinations and our
assessment that Russia views some
defectors as legitimate targets for
assassinations the government has
concluded that it is highly likely that
Russia was responsible for the act
against sergei and julia scrip our
evidence has cemented the view long-held
within the British government but only
no articulated that Sergei scruple is
the man Putin wanted dead he is by now
familiar as a cheerful Salisbury
pensioner caught on CCTV at his local
store buying milk bacon and cashing in a
lottery scratch card but to Russia's
president this former Russian
intelligence officer is a traitor
this is mr. screw pal being arrested in
2006 for selling secrets
two Britons mi6 the 66 year old was
jailed in Russia and only freed to come
to Britain after a spy swap in 2010
together with his 33 year old daughter
Yulia
he remains critically ill in hospital
sergeant Nick Bailey one of the first to
attend to the scruples is serious but
stable
the Nova choc nerve agent used to attack
them is the most deadly nerve agent ever
made hard to detect with a reversible
effect it's ten times more potent than
VX the chemical used in this the
assassination of the half-brother of
North Korean leader Kim jong-un by two
women who rubbed it in his face using
cloths the Nova choc group of chemicals
were developed by the Soviet Union in
the 1970s and 80s they can be dispersed
in an ultrafine powder that's inhaled
ingested or absorbed through the skin
like all nerve agents nabhi chakra
Michals worked by blocking an enzyme
that's active in the nervous system
this causes muscles to contract
involuntarily potentially leading to
cardiac arrest or as fixation hello my
name is Hannah
I'm from Sky News are you mister miss a
enough funeral nor bichang like the
man's Sky News track down behind the
gates of this home in Princeton New
Jersey
vilmer Zion off nose Nova choc because
he produced it and so appalled was he by
his creation this chemical weapons
scientists fled to the United States and
blew the whistle on toxic production for
which he says there is no cure no give
only antidotes but antidotes only
temporarily saving you love there not
kill what about the general public in
the UK who may have come into contact
with trace amounts of Navi shock I
suppose it's a very bad because even the
very small doses very small
still they very effective and then can
seconds could be in years probably
absolutely public health England has
responded to that interview stating it
has been working very closely with the
police and national experts on chemical
weapons since the start of the incident
it says our risk assessment is based on
knowledge of the chemical used our
advice remains that the risk to the
general public is low if inadvertently
someone did become ill and it was
established that it was exposure to the
nerve agent that caused their problems
the government would be in a very
difficult position because it would then
be accused of having known but done
nothing about it police inquiries have
expanded in Salisbury but this is no
normal investigation where there is a
scene of interest there is potential
danger it's a job of chemical analysis
first three scrutiny second which
doesn't speed the investigative process
this is the mill pub where Sergey and
Yulia drank on the Sunday we saw items
bagged and laid out at the rear of the
building there's a forensic tent in
place of the cemetery with the remains
of sergey's wife and son are buried this
was the scenes beneath supermarket
carpark a cordon was placed on the top
level of the multi-story and shoppers
were told to move their cars
it's thought police wanted to retrieve a
particular vehicle
six miles outside Salisbury we saw white
van being taken away it's not clear why
what was clear was the extent of
precautions taken by the officers and
soldiers involved these are the
last-known movements of Sergey and Yulia
on the Sunday they were targeted they
went to the malting shopping center in
Salisbury and had lunch in zzs between
220 and 335 after lunch they took a
short walk to the mill pub police are
interested in CCTV from market walk it
shows a couple strolling past a gym at
3:47 p.m. Sergey and Yulia were found
unconscious on a bench emergency
services were called around 4:15 p.m.
this is the couple captured by CCTV they
may have nothing to do with what
happened police want to be sure they
also want to trace circuits cripples red
BMW both were seen in it over a 45
minute period a couple of hours before
succumbing to the nerve agent the public
again to continue to see a great deal of
police activity in and around the city
including potentially more cauldrons
being erected but please don't be
alarmed it is necessary as part of this
major investigation by the
counterterrorism policing Network in
truth it may last many weeks this is the
scene at Sergey scruples house there are
still forensic tents in the garden and
in between our items bagged up and
awaiting collection police have handed
questionnaires to neighbors their
intelligence gathering on the spy next
door ever since the investigation
started we've had police officers
knocking on the door to check our Wi-Fi
they would leave everyone with lists the
questions asking how we know him do we
know where he lives do we see any
suspicious activity going on display
sickly anything that can help them the
UK pointing the finger towards Russian
President Vladimir Putin has chilled an
already cold relationship London has
told Moscow that without an adequate
explanation it will regard the Salisbury
incident as
lawful use of force on British soil
where there's an ant attack you know
whether there's no legal use of force
then the right to self-defense in
international law is there and all
options are open subject to the United
Nations and so let's see what happens in
the Security Council where Russia will
almost certainly veto any resolution
that is before russia's Foreign Minister
said it had nothing to do with the
Salisbury incident issuing a denial and
a complaint the rumors first started
being spread by practically every member
of the British government that the
substance crippled was poisoned which
came from the Russian Federation we
immediately made an official request to
gain access to this substance so that
our experts could carry out an analysis
we also asked her access to all the
facts associated with the investigation
given that one of the victims is Yulia
scribble a Russian citizen gospel in
response to this completely legal
request we have received an
incomprehensible response which broadly
comes down to the fact that these legal
requests have been refused
while investigations continue in
Salisbury Britain's Home Secretary has
announced an inquiry into 14 deaths with
alleged links to Russia as the UK charts
our cause for confrontation it's
reaching out to allies some are reaching
back well it sounds to me I'm speaking
to Teresa mate today it sounds to me
like it would be Russia based on all of
the evidence they have I don't know if
they've come to a conclusion but she's
calling me today as soon as we get the
facts straight if we agree with them we
will condemn Russia or whoever it may be
but I have not spoken to our speaker or
sometime today the world has been
watching events in this quiet corner of
Wilshire the world has a stake in how it
unfolds and how far people installs but
they are still grasping the unreality of
what happened in their midst
far beyond here lies the grim reality of
confrontation public safety will be
restored in time the political fallout
will last much longer